c'est ce jour anniversaire qu'a choisi
le tribunal de grenoble pour rendre son
jugement dans le procès des sept membres
d'un commando anti avortement qui au
mois d'octobre dernier s'étaient
enchaînés aux grilles d'un hôpital où
sont pratiquées les interruptions
volontaires de grossesse à grenoble
françoise collet et philippe iv c'était
en octobre dernier à l'hôpital michallon
de grenoble une dizaine de personnes
s'enchaînent dans le bloc opératoire où
l'on pratique des avortements
un mois plus tard dans un climat
passionnel le commando comparaît devant
le tribunal correctionnel
parmi les prévenus un moine bénédictin
qui ne jurent que par la loi de dieu
pour entrave à l'interruption de
grossesse le procureur avait requis
quatre à six mois de prison avec sursis
aujourd'hui le tribunal a rendu son
jugement trois mois de prison avec
sursis et 5000 francs d'amendé c'est
trop nous allons faire appel et s'il
faut nous poursuivrons prod qu'elles
s'échangent encore européenne face au
défenseur du droit des enfants avant la
naissance
les partisans de l'avortement se disent
déçus de ce jugement des centres liger
encourage des opposants reconduire de
telles actions
vous savez qu'en france il ya eu depuis
quatre ans plus d'une centaine de
centres ivg qui ont attaqué et les
jugements sont extrêmement faibles
partout
les défenseurs de l'avortement ont tout
de même fêté les 20 ans de la loi veil
car c'est ici à grenoble est né en 1961
le premier planning familial de france